ich sehe da wo mit einen ganz
gefährlichen trend dass sich
flächendeckend in der politik aber im
moment sind die grünen die meister drin
wer politisch anderer meinung ist der
gefährdet menschenleben
das ist auf einmal die
argumentationslinie da ist von mord die
rede
rufmord der stelle müssen wir den speed
einblenden von oliver krischer der ja
über armin laschet ja eigentlich genau
das gesagt ja wir sehen ihn spielt
eingeblendet diese lasche politik kostet
überall auf der welt gerade in kanada
menschen das leben weiteres beispiel was
erstmal aus dem anderen bereich kommt
aber er sozusagen in der rhetorik in der
totalitären rhetorik vielleicht zeigen
wir den tweet noch einmal kurz dass
unsere zuschauer ihn sich anschauen
können in der totalitären rhetorik dem
schon wahnsinnig ähnlich ist was ist
passiert armin laschet in nordrhein
westfalen möchte sozusagen die
abstandsregelung wie weit muss ein
windrad von einem haus entfernt steht
etwas vergrößern
damit es nicht die ganze zeit vom
fenster diesen sogenannten disco effekt
gibt das sehen die grünen jetzt als
klimafeindliche politik und sagen
tatsächlich die politik von armin
laschet kostet leben auch da wieder das
argumentationsmuster wer nicht unserer
meinung ist wer nicht grün ist wenn
nicht die richtige gesinnung hat der ist
nichts anderes als ein wahrer ein
rufmörder ein kriegstreiber im krieg
starben menschen oder wie armin laschet
direkt hier
die beschuldigung immerhin vom
stellvertretenden fraktionschef der
grünen jemand dessen politik unmittelbar
leben auf der ganzen welt kostet das
sind unsägliche entgleisung die zeigen
wie blank die nerven bei den grünen
derzeit liegen